Que feriez-vous si votre pays était envahi par l'armée d'un pays voisin ?
Vous cacher, fuir, résister ou rejoindre l'armée ?
Du jour au lendemain, c'est LA question que des millions de jeunes ukrainiens ont été obligés de se poser.
Et c'est une question qui va changer évidemment le cours de leur vie, mais peut-être aussi le cours de l'histoire.
Alors, à quoi ça ressemble réellement de vivre dans un pays en guerre?
Pour répondre à cette question, on a choisi de se rendre sur place, et c'est ce que vous vous apprêtez à voir aujourd'hui.
Alors, pour se rendre dans un pays en guerre, ce n'est pas si facile.
D'abord, pour être en règle et assuré, il faut récupérer un certain nombre d'éléments.
Déjà une carte de presse ukrainienne, ce qui nous permet de nous déplacer avec un peu plus de liberté dans le pays.
En évitant notamment les couvre-feux le soir.
On a aussi dû récupérer des trousses de secours, on ne sait jamais, mais aussi des gilets pare-balles,
qui sont en fait obligatoires vis-à-vis de notre assurance.
Pour se rendre en Ukraine depuis la France, il n'y a pas de vol direct,
puisque l'espace aérien est fermé dans le pays depuis le premier jour de la guerre.
On a donc pris un vol pour la Pologne, et puis on s'est rendu à la frontière avec l'Ukraine.
Et c'est là que tout a réellement débuté.
Là on est à Chelm, un des points les plus à l'est de la Pologne.
Et on s'apprête à rentrer dans ce train-là.
Ça va être un peu notre maison sur les 14 prochaines heures,
puisque c'est ce train-là de nuit qui va nous amener jusqu'à Kiev.
Ce train à couchette est à la fois très classique et très particulier.
Classique parce qu'à priori il y a tout ce qu'il faut pour passer une bonne nuit
et passer les 14 prochaines heures confortablement.
Et en même temps, on comprend qu'on est très clairement en zone de guerre.
Déjà première chose, on vient de passer 3-4 heures de contrôle aux frontières entre la Pologne et l'Ukraine.
Par ailleurs, on le voit ici, toutes les vitres de ce train sont recouvertes comme ça de scotch,
avec un objectif très clair, faire en sorte qu'en cas d'explosion ou de souffle,
les vitres n'aillent pas sur nous tout simplement.
Et enfin, dernière chose, à l'instant le responsable de la rame vient de nous dire d'éteindre les lumières
pour faire en sorte que le train ne soit pas visible et que ce ne soit pas une cible pour les Russes.
Donc on va éteindre les lumières tout de suite et essayer d'aller dormir.
À notre arrivée en Ukraine, on prend la route pour la banlieue de Kyiv.
Et sur le trajet, les destructions que l'on aperçoit témoignent de combats très violents.
Lui c'est Andriy et c'est notre chauffeur pour la semaine.
Au début de la guerre, sa femme et sa fille ont fui directement vers la Pologne.
Lui n'est pas autorisé à quitter l'Ukraine car comme tous les hommes de 18 à 60 ans,
il pourrait être un jour mobilisé pour aller combattre.
Des contrôles comme celui-là, on en a vécu quasiment à chaque fois qu'on prenait la voiture.
L'armée ukrainienne a mis en place des checkpoints un petit peu partout sur les routes du pays,
mais particulièrement sur celle-ci, car il y a encore quelques mois,
les Russes ont tenté de l'emprunter pour envahir Kyiv.
Irpin, en banlieue, à tout juste 30 minutes de Kyiv.
Ici, effectivement, une grande majorité des bâtiments a été touchée
et surtout au moins 200 habitants ont été tués dans les affrontements.
Au début de l'invasion, le 24 février 2022, l'armée russe a en fait envahi l'Ukraine
par l'est, le sud, mais aussi par le nord,
et ce grâce à l'autorisation de la Biélorussie, alliée de Vladimir Poutine.
L'objectif est alors le suivant, s'emparer le plus rapidement possible de Kyiv,
et cette ville d'Irpin est justement la dernière étape avant la capitale.
Ce quartier résidentiel a été au cœur de ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la bataille d'Irpin
et par exemple, sur cet immeuble-là, c'est des dizaines de familles qui habitaient avant.
On le voit, les combats ont été très intenses.
Aujourd'hui, il n'y a plus que 5 familles qui vivent ici.
Et parmi les habitants encore présents, il y a Volodymyr, 44 ans.
Lors de notre arrivée, il vient rapidement à notre rencontre
et il me propose de monter sur le toit de cette immeuble.
Depuis le dernier étage de ce bâtiment-là, on voit l'ampleur de cette bataille d'Irpin
avec des traces d'obus absolument partout sur ce bâtiment
et des impacts d'obus, on en a par exemple sur le bâtiment en face à droite
ou encore en face, on le voit, l'hôpital d'Irpin qui a été complètement bombardé lors de cette bataille.
À seulement 5 km d'Irpin et toujours dans la banlieue de Kyiv,
une deuxième ville a été envahie et occupée par l'armée russe, il s'agit de Boutcha.
Si vous en avez déjà entendu parler, c'est parce que Boutcha est aujourd'hui
l'un des symboles de l'horreur de cette guerre.
Et c'est pour cette raison que j'ai décidé d'y aller.
Sur place, j'ai rendez-vous avec Mitya, il a 22 ans
et pendant les premières semaines d'occupation, il est resté ici à Boutcha.
Où étais-tu le 24 février?
Le 25 mars 2022, après un mois d’occupation,
la Russie annonce le retrait de se soldats présents dans la région autour de Kyiv.
Officiellement, pour le gouvernement russe, il s’agit d’un changement de stratégie
mais pour l’Ukraine, il s’agit d’une victoire, celle d’avoir repoussé l’armée russe.
Nous sommes alors à la fin du mois de mars, et le monde découvre ce que l’on appelle aujourd’hui le massacre de Boutcha.
Près de 300 corps de civils sont alors découverts en pleine rue ou enterrés dans des fausses communes.
Les photos et les vidéos prises par les habitants jouent alors un rôle primordial et viennent alimenter l'enquête sur ces crimes de guerre.
Sur ta chaîne Youtube, on voit que tu as filmé un certain nombre de choses que tu as postées ensuite.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a poussé à filmer et à documenter tout ça?
Irpin et Boutcha ont été le terrain d'affrontements pendant plusieurs semaines.
Même si ces villes ont tout fait pour tenter d'empêcher les soldats russes d'accéder à Kyiv,
la capitale n'a pas été épargnée pour autant par les combats.
Olha habite à Kyiv et comme Mitya, elle n'a pas voulu fuir si bien que le 24 février,
quand les premières sirènes retentissent et que l'invasion débute,
elle se réfugie dans le sous-sol de cet immeuble où habite sa mère.
Ah c'est en bas là ?
Il faut pas être grand ici.
10 personnes ici ?
On voit sur la caméra qu'il y a de la brume, c'est que c'est très humide et très chaud ici,
on le sent directement alors que nous ça fait que 30 secondes qu'on est là,
mais toi ça fait rester deux jours du coup ici.
Olha va donc passer deux nuits dans ce sous-sol avec une dizaine de personnes avant de se réfugier dans le métro,
et c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment-là que j'avais eu l'occasion de discuter avec elle à distance,
à l'occasion d'un live qu'on avait fait sur le sujet.
Comme elle, des milliers d'habitants de Kyiv ont donc vécu sous terre pendant les premières semaines de l'invasion russe,
dans ces stations de métro aménagées pour servir d'abris anti-bombes.
Alors la situation est tristement différente depuis notre retour à Paris et je vous en reparle juste après,
mais quand on y était, on a été surpris de voir que les habitants ne paniquaient pas
quand les sirènes d'alerte ou frappes aériennes retentissaient dans la ville,
comme si à Kyiv, la vie était presque revenue à la normale.
Les habitants se promènent dans la rue, les magasins et les restaurants ont rouvert,
et même les spectacles ont repris.
Anna est humoriste et le 24 février, elle devait se produire à Kharkiv,
une ville située à l'est de l'Ukraine.
Est-ce que tu as pensé à partir ou est-ce que tu as souhaité rester ?
Nous sommes dans le petit village de Kolychivka,
à 140 km de Kiev, tout au nord de l'Ukraine.
Cette région a été occupée par l'armée russe pendant un mois,
et elle a notamment été lourdement bombardée par des obus comme celui-ci,
des obus envoyés depuis des lance-roquettes que l'on appelle des grades.
Une centaine de jeunes bénévoles est arrivée ce week-end à Kolychivka,
tous sont membres de l'organisation Repair Together,
et leur objectif est d'aller réparer ces maisons dévastées par la guerre en Ukraine.
Olha y participe pour la première fois.
Le village de Kolychivka a été libéré par l'armée ukrainienne au tout début du mois d'avril,
après cinq semaines d'affrontements où de nombreuses habitations ont été détruites.
C'est le cas de la maison de Kateryna.
Où étiez-vous quand ça est arrivé ?
Quel regard portez-vous sur cette guerre qui se déroule depuis plusieurs mois ?
Merci beaucoup et bon courage.
Bon courage.
Si Kateryna ne ressent aucune haine envers les russes aujourd’hui, ce n’est pas forcément le cas de tous les ukrainiens.
Ils étaient en fait nombreux à avoir des amis ou des proches vivant en Russie,
mais aujourd’hui, beaucoup ont coupé les liens et ressentent une colère grandissante.
Retour à Boutcha dans la banlieue de Kyiv.
Quand l’armée russe est arrivée ici, Mitya s’est rapidement porté volontaire pour défendre sa ville
en rejoignant la défense territoriale du pays qui lutte aux côtés de l’armée.
C’est forcément particulier d’avoir une grenade et une arme dans sa chambre quand on a une vingtaine d’années.
Tu pensais te retrouver dans cette situation un jour ?
Dans la vie de tous les jours, Mitya est skateur professionnel.
Avant la guerre, il ne savait donc pas se servir d'une arme.
Mais aujourd’hui, il se sent prêt à défendre sa ville.
Si Mitya est resté à Boucha, des millions de jeunes ukrainiens ont choisi d'aller encore plus loin dans la volonté de s'engager
en allant combattre directement sur le front de la guerre.
D’ailleurs, on était en contact avec plusieurs de ces militaires sur le front à l’est du pays
On avait prévu de les rencontrer sur place mais finalement, l’avancée des troupes russes à l’est les a empêcher de se libérer
Aujourd'hui, Mitya peut à nouveau sortir de chez lui et faire du skate.
Un geste simple qui lui était pourtant impossible pendant l'occupation russe.
Qu'est-ce que tu ressens quand tu vois ces bâtiments, ces maisons qui ont été touchées ?
Vivre en paix, c'est ce que souhaitent tous les ukrainiens que nous avons rencontrés sur place.
Mitya a donc repris le skate et Anna a repris ses spectacles.
Nous la retrouvons donc à Kyiv après deux heures de show.
Sur le fait de rire à propos de la guerre, est-ce que tu as l'impression que c'est accepté par les gens ici ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des gens à qui ça ne plaît pas ? Comment est-ce que tu vois tout ça ?
À Kolychivka, la journée est terminée.
Les travaux pour reconstruire la maison de Kateryna reprendront donc demain.
Et le soir, les bénévoles se retrouvent tous ensemble pour aller faire la fête.
D'un regard extérieur, certains peuvent trouver ça étonnant ou bizarre de faire la fête dans ce genre de situation.
Toi, comment est-ce que tu le vois ? Ça te semble positif ?
Quelques jours après notre reportage, Kyiv a de nouveau été bombardée.
Et depuis, les bombardements s'enchaînent.
Depuis le 10 octobre, plusieurs grandes villes sont régulièrement ciblées par les attaques russes,
entraînant des coupures d'eau et d'électricité, plongeant les ukrainiens dans le noir et sans chauffage,
parfois pendant plusieurs jours, et ce, en plein hiver.
Et signe de l'incertitude et de la peur dans laquelle la population est plongée aujourd'hui.
À Kyiv, on avait tourné des images dans le quartier de Shevchenko pour vous montrer à quel point la vie semblait avoir repris.
Quelques jours après notre départ, ce même quartier et ces mêmes rues ont été bombardées et détruites.
C'est peut-être, finalement, ce qui résume le mieux le quotidien dans un pays en guerre,
des vagues lueurs d'espoir, dans une incertitude et dans une angoisse permanente.
Ce que vous avez vu dans cette vidéo, c'est la vie de trois jeunes ukrainiens, Olha, Anna et Mitya.
Chacun tente de vivre dans cette guerre au quotidien comme il le peut.
Mais une chose les réunit, c'est cette volonté de se battre pour la paix.
Et je vais leur laisser le mot de la fin.